the i-team has learned about an
investigation into the death of a parole
and probation officer
according to the clark county coroner he
died of a drug overdose
the i-team's vanessa murphy has been
digging into this story since march
she's here now with more on what she
uncovered vanessa
john scott was a parole and probation
officer he was found dead at his home
with the powerful synthetic drug
fentanyl nearby according to the clark
county coroner
the i-team has learned now there's an
investigation as you mentioned
considering his job and how he oversaw
people who were on parole and probation
one question how did scott get the drugs
this clark county coroner report
describes how john scott was found in
his las vegas home
on the morning of march 26th 44 year old
man
lying on the floor of his laundry room
with a plate with white residue
foil with a burn mark a lighter and a
cut straw nearby
a known combination for illicit drug use
metro's overdose response team arrived
and
reported that white residue tested
positive for
fentanyl a powerful synthetic opioid
scott's death caused by drug toxicity
from
fentanyl and alcohol according to the
coroner
scott was a parole and probation officer
for nevada's department of public safety
or dps now the i-team has learned there
are
questions about how scott was obtaining
drugs
and whether he was using his duties as
an officer to get them
through an official records request
submitted by the i-team
dps first only confirmed scott was hired
in 2016.
when we pressed for more answers through
another records request
the i-team received a response stating
in part
the specific circumstances surrounding
the death of mr scott have been the
focus of an independent
investigation by metro the findings by
the coroner's office related to mr
scott's cause of death
raised concerns for dps and the
department
is investigating to determine whether
there have been any internal violations
of law
policy or procedure
according to transparent nevada which
collects salary information for public
employees
scott was a dps officer with total pay
and benefits
of close to 97 thousand dollars
i reached out to metro to find out more
about the investigation and i received
this document citing law enforcement
privilege
open active criminal investigation
basically saying this information needs
to be confidential for now denise back
to you